le braquage s'est déroulé très tôt ce
matin aux alentours de 5h30 on parle de
cinq à six individus armés de fusils à
pompes qui auraient fait irruption dans
cette très discrète entreprise de la
périphérie bisontine vous le voyez nous
sommes devant pas une enceinte passe
d'un panneau pour signaler l'existence
de cette maison qui serait pourtant
connu jusqu'à la place vendôme puis ce
qu'elle travaillerait pour la joaillerie
de luxe
les malfaiteurs étaient donc très bien
renseignés ils auraient brièvement
séquestré la demi-douzaine d'employés
présents sur place au moment des faits
avant de faire main basse sur une
vingtaine de kilos d'or en qu'opposer
lingots ainsi qu'une vingtaine de kilos
de platine attention ces volumes ne sont
pas encore confirmés par le parquet pour
information tout de même le kilo d'or se
négocie actuellement à plus de 37000
euros pour vous donner une petite idée
du butin potentiel les accès de
l'entreprise sont actuellement en boucle
et les experts scientifiques sont
toujours à l'oeuvre à l'intérieur du
bâtiment on nous dit qu'un dispositif de
surveillance a été déployée sur les
réseaux routiers mais les malfaiteurs
visiblement bien renseignés et bien
organisés serait sûrement sont sûrement
loin à l'heure actuelle la brigade de
recherches de la gendarmerie de besançon
s'est vu chargé des enquêtes